ankie voor een new cloud architect
show also the my sandal
do you have cabinets door the google cloud
professional at architect certification
in spe cycles and professionals tumblr
google plus preparing for it will solely
by joris teddy of designing developing
and managing and rupa's and scalable
cloud architecture'  other cloud be
the test like its way to our multiple
choice act on the cover is how to this
time
plan manage secure provision and
optimize the cloud solution
infrastructure
this is great tanks and je by some where
to start
hans of training resources
commercials to them  late and everyone
posters
check it out